[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
up next we have kyy in Minneapolis hey
Kylie welcome to the
show hi hello how can we
help um so I recently just started a new
job um I'm not making too much money
just about I think I'm making 1350 okay
um I started two weeks ago and I was you
know kind of searching for other jobs
too and I got another job offer that
offered me
$18 okay um the thing is is that my
boyfriend is completely unsupportive
about me moving to this other
job um so I'm kind of torn between
staying at this job um making him happy
versus going to this other job and
causing some conflict in our
relationship um okay how pretty what are
you doing now for a
job um I'm currently at Fleet Farm I
just do stocking okay and what's the new
job it would be in a factory um doing
Pete prep okay and why is he
unsupportive of
that um he is I think he has a lot of
history of other people cheating on him
this new job would be working mainly
with not men um so I think he's kind of
an insecurity things okay how old are
you
guys uh I'm 20 he's 19 okay how long
have you guys been
dating about eight months okay do you
think
um anything heading to the
official conversation like do you think
that is he it or are you guys just
dating I'm what was that do you think
that he's is he your husband do you
think like okay yeah he's probably who
I'm gonna end up with or do you think no
we're just dating and we're going to see
what
happens um no we've done a lot of
talking that's the end goal is to
obviously get married you know once
we're in a good place okay so the fact
that it's that serious in a relationship
Kylie does raise a lot of red flags for
me in his insecurity I mean if he's been
cheated John's the relationship expert
I'm let him jump in on most of this but
I'm like dying man if he's If he if he's
you go you go why am I go John no go
ahead go ahead well what I was going to
say is yeah I mean I I mean I understand
that he's like oh man I don't want this
to happen again cuz what I went through
sucks and it hurts but all that fact
that he's putting all of that on you and
it's completely out of jealousy and
insecurity Kylie that's a red that's
that's a problem there are more red
flags here than at the red flag Factory
like where they make red
flags yeah dude I I I mean think about
what he's telling you hey I don't want
you to improve your life
financially because I um will be
uncomfortable H right so I'm going to
attach my lack of trust and my lack of
belief in myself and my La lack of own
personal security I'm going to make you
carry that around to the tune of $5 an
hour that's how little I think of you
and your
trustworthiness okay if you were my
sister I would um tell you to listen to
what the great Jay-Z says and that is to
brush your shoulders off and roll and
here's the problem Kylie so sweeping it
under the rug isn't going to fix it so
what does that mean when you actually
present him that no this is a better job
for me and I I'm I'm going to move
forward how he responds to that Kylie
says a lot about who he is okay okay and
as yeah we're gonna we're gonna be your
big siblings we're I'm going be your big
sister John I'll be your big brother in
this I think that that's and and why I
asked how serious the relationship is
cuz I'm like I just want you to be
very aware and go in to I don't want you
to make a decision a lifelong decision
of something like
marriage when there's conversations like
this happening does that make
sense yeah y absolutely and by the way
he's 18 how many people have cheated on
him between 14 and 18 good
grief no I mean I guess he's had two
girlfriends um before me and they both
cheated on him with the same guy
so dude yeah now you could make this
super interesting if that guy works at
the factory please tell me that's true
please right does he no no not at all we
live about an hour and a half away from
each other I was going to start chanting
Jerry Jerry that would have been awesome
that would have been awesome but listen
um if he had the courage let me let me
try to see both sides of this if he had
the courage to tell you hey I've been
cheated on twice and the fact that
you're going to be working you're going
to be the only woman on the floor at
this Factory and guys are going to be
like treating you like crap they're
going to be cat calling they're going to
be they're they're just going to be all
like I know how those dudes are makes me
super uncomfortable I want to say good
for him for speaking that out loud that
needs to be followed with but I trust
you and if you tell me you can't do this
$18 an hour job even though it's it
would be amazing for you and eventually
when we get married me too um and you
say I can't be around these people I'll
I'll I'll be right there to help you get
your stuff out of there and if you tell
me no this is this is incredible I'm
learning some great stuff I've got a
I've got a leadership track here I'm
going to start $18 an hour I'm going to
stay on I'll be at $25 an hour in a year
and a half awesome but you see like
vulnerability is part of it and so is
trust and you got to have both of those
things right yeah yeah I think that's
you know he did Express though that's
basically how you did and it's just
really the trust part
but listen Rachel and I we just talked
to a lot of couples and here's what
happens if you don't if if you don't
attune to that red flag this next is you
have a you get pregnant and he says yeah
um the mother of my kid doesn't do X Y
and Z and to make him happy I'll just
listen and do it which that gets so
dangerous so fast for who you are Kylie
like on your end so learning to work
through this could be either an eye
opening moment for you Kylie to be like
this doesn't feel great anymore I don't
know how I feel about this or you push
in and it's a great moment of saying
okay this is some conflict and he's
telling me this stuff and I'm speaking
up and we're actually going to work
through this problem together and it
actually strengthens you guys and you
guys become healthier but don't please
don't just sweep it under the rug and do
it because it's it's good for him and
this is what he wants it's not it's not
going to be healthy it doesn't turn into
anything healthy healthy for you or
healthy for your relationship or
possible future marriage like nothing
good comes out of that Kylie
okay okay so how would I I mean you know
that I kind of looked at the place um I
really haven't mentioned that I I wanted
to wait because we live so far away to
from each other to talk to them in
person rather than over text or over the
phone oh y even yall even in the same
community no he Liv about an hour and a
half
away playing boyfriend and girlfriend on
the
internet we see each other every weekend
for about four days
so oh well don't I wouldn't change my
career around him let me just say that
yet you go Kylie you go do what you need
to do and how he responds is going to
say a lot about who he is and who you're
going to decide to be in a relationship
look him in the eye and say I won't
cheat on you and just know you guys are
19 and 20 and I never want to like be
little people because of their age but
also know like you guys are figuring out
life and this is a really good moment
for you Kylie to start practicing what
it looks like for what Kylie needs and
what does Kylie need Kylie needs a
freaking $5 hour raise it's huge it's
huge great humongous and Kye needs to
learn that it's not your job to make
sure everybody else in the world that
their needs get taken care of before
yours okay you have to be able to say
here's what I need and right now you're
looking at like I need groceries and so
I'm going to meet that need and look
them in the ey and say I wanton you
you're doing nothing wrong by taking
this job either like if you were doing
something immoral sure but there's
nothing imal about this you're doing
great and God help you don't cheat on
him with that other guy cuz that just
that's going to be a whole different
phone call if you that well yeah for his
sake Insanity don't do that create your
free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life